au matin du 17 mars les yvelinois ont
découvert des rues désertes
le bruit des voitures a laissé place aux
chants des oiseaux les bars restaurants
cafés théâtres et cinémas ayant fermé le
week-end précédent seuls les commerces
alimentaires les pharmacies et d'autres
magasins de première nécessité sont
restés ouverts en respectant les mesures
sanitaires
mais pour pouvoir se déplacer
l'attestation de déplacement dérogatoire
est devenu obligatoire en cas de
contrôle des forces de l'ordre elle sera
présentée avec le motif du déplacement
bonjour madame je vous demander votre
attestation s'il vous plaît c'est
tellement de domicile
une association e
m'occuper de chasse et michel de
l'association au sujet de mourir les
plus de sony d'accord très bien
fermeture des crèches écoles collèges
lycées et universités
cette année le brevet le baccalauréat
seront évaluées en contrôle continu pour
les cours tout se passe à domicile les
enseignants assurent une continuité
pédagogique en quelques jours
l'ensemble de notre communauté s'est
mise à faire l'école tout à fait
autrement par exemple dans le premier
degré c'est-à-dire les écoles primaires
on a créé en l'espace de deux jours
l'équivalent de 1700 blog pour que les
enseignants puissent mettre leurs
supports les ateliers de lecture déroule
le programme d'une journée les petits
exercices que les élèves font donc
vraiment il ya eu un virage colossal qui
a été pris la veille du confinement lady
biennois avaient rendez vous aux urnes
pour le premier tour des élections
municipales
après les annonces du président emmanuel
macron pas de deuxième tour prévu pour
ces élections
les sept communes saint-quentinoise
concernés devons attendre pour connaître
la date du report qui est toujours
inconnue même si le mois de juin était
évoqué le premier tour il est considéré
comme acquis donc on va prendre des
dispositions pour le report des
dispositions pour les conseils aussi
communautaire d'agglomération pour que
ça puisse continuer à fonctionner ou si
normalement possible et que les le
service public est bien évidemment une
continuité pour faire face à l'afflux de
la maladie dans les villes les médecins
de ville ont organisé l'ouverture des
centres dédiés aux qu'ovide 19 des
centres qui permettent d'accueillir des
patients ayant les symptômes du
coronavirus parmi les personnes touchées
par la maladie on apprenait le 29 mars
le décès de patrick devedjian président
du conseil départemental des
hauts-de-seine qui avait pour projet la
fusion entre les départements yvelines
hauts de seine dans un communiqué son
homologue pierre bédier président du
conseil départemental des yvelines lui
rendaient hommage et mettait un point
d'honneur à poursuivre le rapprochement
des deux départements
face au co vide les yvelinois ont su
montrer leur générosité et leur
solidarité le secours populaire de
trappes s'est mobilisée pour assurer la
continuité des distributions
alimentaires malgré la situation
délicate pour les commerçants des
livraisons à domicile ont été organisées
par quelques fermes de la région des
drive ont également été mis en place
dans quelques petites enseignes vente de
livre de café de chocolat les yvelinois
ont répondu à l'appel des soignants
livraison de repas de traiteur et de
chefs étoilés dans des ehpad et hôpitaux
des offres de réductions ont été
proposés chez certains garagistes des
distribution de masques et de gel hydro
alcoolique ont été remis aux personnels
soignants et des entreprises comme psa à
poissy se sont même engagés dans la
fabrication de 10000 respirateur
artificiel
face à cette situation exceptionnelle
notre entreprise s'est mobilisée
d'une part un groupe de travail d'une
trentaine d'experts à étudier la
meilleure façon de produire les
respirateurs plus rapidement et en
grande quantité en parallèle dans la
mesure où dans notre usine de poissy
nous avons mis en place les mesures de
sécurité sanitaire renforcée pour
protéger nos salariés nous avons décidé
d'y installer un atelier pour produire
le bloc central des respirateurs
artificiels le début du déconfinement
est prévue à la date du 11 mai les
écoles reprendront un rythme scolaire
avec quelques changements
les lieux culturels les restaurants
resteront fermées et les gestes
barrières devant être respectées pour
retrouver une vie un tant soit peu
normal les yvelinois devront attendre
quatre semaines pour commencer la sortie
progressive du confinement